♪
>> Sean: HERE TO EXCLUSIVELY
REACT TO THE DEMOCRATS' FISA
MEMO FORMER TRUMP CAMPAIGN
ASSOCIATE CARTER PAGE.
HOW ARE YOU, SIR?
>> GOOD TO SEE YOU.
>> Sean: YOU ARE NOT A
TRAITOR TO THE COUNTRY.
LET ME GIVE YOU SOME
BACKGROUND HERE SO OUR
AUDIENCE UNDERSTANDS.
BY THE WAY YOU ARE A NAVAL
GRADUATE.
YOU WENT TO ANNAPOLIS?
>> YES.
>> Sean: YOU WERE PART OF A
FOREIGN POLICY ADVISORY
COUNSEL ON THE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN.
THEY MET ONCE AND YOU
WEREN'T THERE.
>> YEAH.
I HAD A PREVIOUS MEETING
SCHEDULED WITH SOME TOP
MILITARY LEADERS VERY FAR
FROM WASHINGTON.
>> Sean: YOU NEVER MET
DONALD TRUMP?
NEVER COMMUNICATED WITH HIM
IN ANY WAY?
>> NO.
YOU YOURSELF AS A JUNIOR
UNDERPAID.
>> UNPAID.
>> Sean: UNPAID ADVISOR.
OKAY.
YOU DID SPEAK AT
COMMENCEMENT CEREMONY MOSCOW
AT THE NEW ECONOMIC SCHOOL.
BY THE WAY PRESIDENT OBAMA
SPOKE THERE, TOO.
>> I HAVE SPOKEN AT A LOT OF
UNIVERSITIES IN MOSCOW GOING
BACK 15 YEARS BUT, YEAH.
>> Sean: YOU LIVED THERE.
WHY DID YOU LIVE IN MOSCOW?
>> BECAUSE IN 2004, MERRILL
LYNCH WAS, YOU KNOW, THEY
MOVED OUT IN 1998 WHEN THE
EMERGING MARKETS CRISIS
OCCURRED.
AND SO 2004 WAS THE FASTEST
GROWTH MARKET IN THE WORLD.
SO THEY -- ME AND ANOTHER
GUY WENT OVER TO GET THE
OFFICE GOING.
>> Sean: YOU ADMITTED TO
LAWMAKERS AND ANYONE ELSE
WHO.
I WON'T ASK YOU BECAUSE YOU
CAN'T TALK ABOUT IT, CAN
YOU.
CERTAIN MEETINGS YOU MIGHT
HAVE HAD.
IN MOSCOW YOU HAD BRIEF
ENCOUNTERS WITH PEOPLE WHO
MAY HAVE BEEN SENIOR
GOVERNMENT OFFICIALS.
>> I SAID HELLO.
ONE OF THE OTHER SPEAKERS AT
THE NEW ECONOMICS SCHOOL WAS
A GOVERNMENT OFFICIAL.
I SAID HELLO AS HE WAS
WALKING DOWN THE OFF THE
STAGE.
>> Sean: THAT'S THE DEPUTY
PRIME MINISTER OF RUSSIA.
>> YEAH.
>> Sean: 10 SECONDS?
>> NOT EVEN.
I HAVE BEEN ASKING TO TRY TO
GET FOOTAGE OF THAT.
AND I HAVE BEEN ASKED ABOUT
THAT IN VARIOUS
INTERROGATIONS, LITERALLY.
>> Sean: IN ALL YOUR TIME,
ON THE CAMPAIGN OR NOT ON
THE CAMPAIGN, DID ANYBODY IN
RUSSIA EVER SUGGEST TO YOU
THAT THEY HAD NEGATIVE
INFORMATION ON HILLARY?
>> NOT ONE WORD.
NOTHING WHATSOEVER.
AND NOT EVEN A GLIMPSE OF AN
WHOEVER OFFER.
>> Sean: ANYONE EVER SUGGEST
TO YOU IN ANY WAY THAT THERE
WAS A HACKING THAT THEY WERE
AWARE OF?
>> ABSOLUTELY NOT.
YOU KNOW, I HEARD ABOUT IT
IN THE NEWS, EVENTUALLY.
>> Sean: YOU ARE IDENTIFIED
A LOT IN THIS STEELE
DOSSIER, YOU KNOW.
>> YEAH.
>> Sean: PAGE 9 OF IT SAYS
THAT YOU HELD MEETINGS WITH
TWO EYE
TWO IYE
TWO IGORS.
I'M GOING TO SAY IT THE
WRONG WAY THE VATICAN.
>> DID THAT EVER HAPPEN?
>> I HAD NOT EVEN HEARD -- I
STARTED WHEN I HEARD THE
WORD -- THEY STARTED CALLING
ME "WALL STREET JOURNAL" WAS
THE FIRST THAT CALLED ME IN
JULY OF 2016.
AND I STARTED -- I KEPT
GETTING THESE CALLS FROM
PEOPLE FOR THE NEXT COUPLE
MONTHS UNTIL IT FINALLY
BROKE IN SEPTEMBER.
>> Sean: IS ANYTHING WRITTEN
IN THE STEELE DOSSIER TRUE.
>> NOT ONE WORD.
>> Sean: NOT ONE WORD.
THEY WERE COMPLETELY FALSE.
>> IT'S A LAUGHABLE JOKE.
ABSOLUTELY.
>> Sean: I KNOW TREY GOWDY
ASKED YOU THIS.
WHAT FACTUAL INACCURACIES
STAND OUT THE MOST AGAINST
YOU?
>> THE COMPLETE
RIDICULOUSNESS OF IT ALL,
SEAN.
>> Sean: DO YOU THINK YOU
WOULD HAVE BEEN CHARGED BY
THE SPECIAL COUNSEL NOW IF
THEY HAD ANY EVIDENCE
CONSIDERING THAT THAT FISA
WARRANT GAVE THEM AN
OPPORTUNITY TO GET EVERY
TEXT, EVERY EMAIL.
EVERY PHONE CALL YOU EVER
MADE?
WOULDN'T THAT HAVE LED TO AN
INDICTMENT BY NOW?
>> YOU KNOW, I'M NOT -- YOU
KNOW, I DON'T TALK ABOUT
THOSE THINGS.
BUT TYPICALLY, IF ANYONE
WOULD HAVE -- I HAVE NEVER
BEEN GIVEN ANY INFORMATION
THAT I AM UNDER ANY SERIOUS
CONSIDERATION OVER RECENT
MONTHS.
>> Sean: I HAVE NO
INFORMATION THE RUSSIAN
GOVERNMENT OR ANYONE
ASSOCIATED WITH IT PLAYED A
ROLE IN THE 2016 ELECTION.
YOU ADDED YOUR VISITS TO
MOSCOW YOU WERE NEVER
APPROACHED IN ANY SHAPE,
MANNER OR FORM.
WHAT COULD
WHAT DOULD
WHAT DO YD
WHAT DO YOU MAKE IF THAT'S
TRUE WHAT YOU SAID BECAUSE
YOU SAID IT UNDER OATH AND
YOU SAID IT TO THE HOUSE
INTELLIGENCE COMMITTEE?
>> SEAN, YOU KNOW, IN THAT
CONTEXT, I HAVE TO THANK YOU
BECAUSE YOU HAVE BEEN THE
EDWARD WHERE MURROW OF THIS
WHOLE PROCESS.
PROCESS.
>> Sean: THE MEDIA IS GOING
TO LOVE THAT COMMENT.
SO COMPLETELY OUT OF CONTROL
GOING BACK REALLY A YEAR AND
A HALF FROM NOW.
SO YOUR AND YOUR TEAM THEY
USED TO CALL IT THE MURROW
BOYS.
YOUR TEAM WITH GREGG AND
SARA AND EVERYONE.
TO DIG THROUGH AND ACTUALLY
GET TO THE BOTTOM OF THINGS.
I MEAN, THERE IS A LOT OF
PEOPLE.
>> Sean: HAS THE COUNTRY
BEEN LIED TO BY THE MEDIA
AND BY ADAM SCHIFF ON A
REGULAR BASIS?
>> IT'S BEEN NONSTOP,
ABSOLUTELY.
AND THAT'S THE FUNNY THING
ABOUT THIS -- THE MEMO FROM
SATURDAY.
IT'S JUST A CONTINUATION OF
THE SAME GAME THE DNC HAS
BEEN PLAYING SINCE THE
SUMMER OF 2016.
>> DO YOU KNOW CHRISTOPHER
STEELE?
NOT MICHAEL.
IS HE MY FRIEND.
>> NEVER MET HIM.
>> THE GOVERNMENT BY THE WAY
SPIED ON YOU FOR DIFFERENT
WARRANTS FOR A FULL YEAR.
>> YOU KNOW THE MEMOS
ANYTHING THAT WOULD
IMPLICATE YOU ASSOCIATE
YOURSELVES WITH RUSSIANS TO
IMPACT IN THIS COUNTRY.
>> I HAVE NO FEAR
WHATSOEVER.
IT'S LIKE MAP LIBS ON THIS.
TYPICALLY YOU HAVE TO PUT IN
A WORD AND COMES OUT WITH A
CRAZY SAYING.
ER YOU KNOW, IT'S ALREADY
THE CRAZY IDEA AND THE
10-PAGE MEMO AND THEN
WHATEVER IS UNDERNEATH IN
THESE BLACKED OUT BOXES I'M
SURE WOULD BE EVEN MORE
CRAZY.
>> Sean: YOU KNOW THE STEELE
DOSSIER HE CASED OUT ON THE
TRUTH OF HIS OWN DOSS YEA?
>> MEANTIME, AMAZE U.ING
KNEW DEAF FOLLOW
IMMIGRATION.
>> LOU SUING.
>> BOTH INC. WHICH OBSERVES
YAHOO NEWS AS WELL AS HUFING HUF
YAHOO NEWS AS WELL AS HUFING HUI
YAHOO NEWS AS WELL AS HUFING HUG
YAHOO NEWS AS WELL AS HUFING HUO
YAHOO NEWS AS WELL AS HUFING HUN
YAHOO NEWS AS WELL AS HUFING HUP
YAHOO NEWS AS WELL AS HUFING HUS
YAHOO NEWS AS WELL AS HUFING HU.
>> Sean: MEABS OTHERS WHEN
IT'S ALL SAID AND DONE.
>> WHEN YOU LOOK AT FAKE
INTEL REPORT OF
JANUARY 6TH,2017.
TWO WEEKS BEFORE THE
INAUGURATION ATTACKING
REALLY THROWING UP A LOT OF
DIRT ON THE INCOMING NEW
ADMINISTRATION LEAVING OPEN
THESE -- ALL THESE
QUESTIONS, THERE'S TWO
THEMES TO IT.
ONE IS THE HACKING.
AND WE ALL KNOW I HAVE BEEN
HACKED NOW.
AND THE OTHER IS THE FAKE
NEWS MEDIA.
MY LAWSUIT RIGHT NOW IS
FOCUSED ON THE FAKE NEWS
MINISTRY.
AND I'M SUING BROADCASTING
BOARD OF GOVERNORS WHICH IS
THE THUNDER.
I HAVE BEEN BACK AND FORTH
WITH DOJ MANY MONTHS NOW.
SO FAR THEY HAVE BEEN I
KICKING AND SCREAMING.
NOW THAT THE TRUTH COMES OUT